hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich möchte heute nochmal eine verdammt
harte machen und zwar nochmal zu dem
thema mini maus und diese torte habe ich
jetzt etwas anders gestaltet das ist
jetzt auch eine zweistöckige motiv torte
und in diesem video werde ich euch jetzt
zeigen wie ich sie dekoriert habe und
zusammengesetzt habe und die einzelnen
rezepte die findet ihren einfach später
in der infobox den teilen habe ich jetzt
einfach übersprungen damit es jetzt
etwas schneller geht und ich finde die
torte optisch sehr gelungen vor allem
hat mir hier unten
diese reichen also von dem mini maus
rock und daneben da oben diese mini maus
köpfe die gehen auch ganz einfach
wirklich mit ganz einfachen ausstechen
und ich denke da freut sich einfach
jedes kind darüber
und jetzt will ich sagen wir starten
einfach direkt und legen los
für die mini maus torte praktiziert
einen kuchen eurer wahl
ich habe jetzt einen leckeren
schokoladenkuchen vorbereitet und zwar
habe ich hier einmal zwei bilden mit 26
cm durchmesser hier mit 20 zentimetern
durchmesser zwei stück ich werde sie
auch trinken mit etwas kirschwasser mit
kirschsaft meine ich natürlich und hier
habe ich etwas zeit gesagt danach
vorbereitet und die rezepte für diesen
tag danach und für die kuchen böden
findet ihr am ende des videos oder
einfach auf meinem blog sozialismus
blog.de da habe ich nämlich schon mal
die rezepte vorbereitet und auch für
euch abgefilmt und ich wage es zuerst
mal mit den kleinen an
ich muss jetzt nämlich die böden schönen
vorbereiten und mit ghanas bestreichen
damit wir eben schön glatt werden
dazu sehe ich die böden einmal kurz
durch
jetzt habe ich hier auch zwei kuchen
platten einmal mit 20 cm einmal mit 25
zentimeter durchmesser und die nehme ich
jetzt als untergrund für die torten
damit ich sie später auch schön stapeln
kann
diebe streiche ich jetzt mit etwas ganz
stand bleibt auch der kuchen draufkleben
dann kommt direkt der erste boten drauf
und den trinke ich jetzt mit etwas
und fülle die einzelnen böden jetzt auch
mit etwas tat bitter ghana
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel in oslo
kathrin benutzen oder mit etwas anderen
befüllen
dann kommt der zweite boden drauf und
dann geht es einfach immer so weiter
und jetzt seht ihr auch hier ich hab da
ganz oben jetzt den flachen boden
draufgesetzt und die deckel innen rein
versteckt damit ich oben einfach eine
schöne gerade habe und jetzt fühle ich
mit der restlichen ganache hier noch die
lücken aus damit die torte schön glatt
wird und dann steige ich auch schon die
erste schicht drüber
die tote muss jetzt erst mal in den
kühlschrank damit die erste schicht des
fest werden kann
denn ansonsten würde sie jetzt so sagt
bröseln und ich stelle jetzt kurz den
kühlschrank und bereitet derzeit auch
schon mal im zweiten zu und dann sehen
wir uns gleich wieder wenn ich die torte
richtig sind ganz streichen
es kommt noch mehr zweite schicht trafen
die schicht solltet ihr jetzt richtig
schön glatt streichen
damit ihr die perfekte unterlage habt
für den fortschritt
ich habe die torte fertig glatt
eingestrichen und geht es jetzt noch mal
kurz im kühlschrank in der zwischenzeit
streiche ich auch die große torte noch
mal schön glatt und dann kann können wir
gleich schon direkt mit der dekoration
beginnen die beiden torten sind jetzt
schön kalt erwischt als bereits mit der
dekoration beginnen und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier etwas von dort hier habe ich
etwas weißem von dorf und zwar gibt es
diese im ein kilo eimer später brauche
ich noch etwas rot und etwas schwarz und
etwas becker stärker auf jeden fall und
denn von dort tätig jetzt erst mal weich
mit etwas palm ihn in meinen händen da
etwas kokosfett und ich sah mir ist es
mittlerweile die kann jetzt ganz fleißig
dabei helfen
da hilft mir halt später okay wie du
willst
und den von don hall ich jetzt auf etwas
becker stärke aus und ich mach das nicht
so für den unteren teil weil ich es
ziemlich dünn aus als 12 mm weil ich da
noch etwas trüber macher an dekorationen
und für den oberen für den kleinen rolex
etwas dicker aus etwa 3 bis 4 mm
jetzt soll ich das hier auf den aus
wollstoff aus
hol mir die torte auf den platz und weil
jetzt hier die oberfläche so ein
bisschen angetrocknet ist nämlich etwas
back trance ring und befeuchtet die
oberfläche dann klebt der von dort
nämlich schön an der garage an und ich
hab dann keine luft lagen darunter
und jetzt kann es nur noch darüber
gerollt werden
und jetzt schön mit den händen
glattstreichen der bunteren ist jetzt
mich schlimm wenn es nicht zu glatt wird
denn da kommt er gleich noch was drüber
und jetzt immer von oben nach unten
glattstreichen dann gehen auch die
falten an den seiten schön
die überreste nehme ich dann mit einem
marzipan messer weg dann könnt ihr
nämlich besser arbeiten wenn dieser rest
hier weg ist weil der zieht ansonsten
denn von da weg und dann kann er eben
reißen
und jetzt nehme ich mir jetzt weise von
der kälte und glätte damit die
oberfläche und auch die seiten
ich mache es kurz genau und du am rand
mit diesem klettern könnt ihr zb schön
die seiten von dann haben wir auch immer
hier so einen rechten winkel und dann
nehme ich für hier oben diesen kanten
format dann gibt's einmal den eckig und
einmal in rund und da muss man sich da
oben nicht so viel mühe geben denn der
kann in form da macht es dann richtig
schön glatt
die beiden tagen habe ich jetzt im
kühlschrank gestellt und möchte jetzt
meinen kickboard vorbereiten und zwar
werde ich darauf die torte präsentieren
das sitzen ältere skateboard das habe
ich schon mal verwendet aber ich werde
es jetzt gleich überziehen deswegen ist
nicht schlimm dass selbst ein paar
flecken mit drauf sind
also wenn ihr sowas überziehen wollt
könnt ihr auch gerne im cache bot zwei
oder drei mal benutzen und ich habe ziel
bereits schwarzen von dort hinausgerollt
das war jetzt 500 gramm und die platte
ist etwa fünf zentimeter größer als die
torte diebe streiche ich mit etwas
zucker kleber dann klebt da gleich davon
darstellen dran
jetzt habe ich hier so eine struktur
roller mit herzchen drauf und damit
strukturiere ich den den von deutschen
ein bisschen
und dann könnte diese matte darüber
lägen also denn die von der matte als
schönen untergrund ich finde dann immer
ganz toll wenn die platte auch zur torte
dazu passt und deswegen nehme ich jetzt
nur schwarz weil ich ja auch viele mini
maus elemente haben
jetzt hier nur noch den rahmen zauber
wegschneiden
die platte stelle ich jetzt zum trocknen
auf die seite und homepage schon meine
dekoration und für die torten
ich möchte auf die torte jetzt noch zwei
ohren aufbringen von der mini maus und
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier schwarz der
modelle schokolade
die gibt es ja in so kleinen 100 gramm
päckchen und die reicht mir jetzt auch
aus für beide ohren
ihr könnt noch von der benutzten mist
aber unbedingt zellulose private cnc
einknicken
das mache ich jetzt hier auch damit
schneller trocknet ihr könnt aber wenn
ihr das schon vorbereiten wollte am tag
vorher machen dann braucht ihr auch den
zellulose prüfe ob das kenne ich jetzt
einmal kurz durch weil das wird ja von
alleine fest weil ja die modelle
schokolade durch hand wärme weich wird
und später beim erkalten eben wieder
kalt wird
jetzt habe ich jetzt weiß so
abstandhalter so holzstäbe und da kann
ich die schokolade dairy schokolade
jetzt auf 5 mm stärke aus
jetzt nehme ich mir hier sondern aus
regiert hat achteinhalb zentimeter im
durchmesser und steche ziel zwei kreise
auf ihr könnt aber wenn ihr nicht so ein
ausstecher habt auch zum beispiel ein
glas nehmen
und zum befestigen nämlich zwei stück
spieße mit dem kann ich später die ohren
einfach in die torte reinstecken und die
klebe ich jetzt mit etwas zucker kleber
in den ohren fest
die ohren dass ich jetzt kurz durch
trocknen und kann ihn derzeit schon mal
mit der unteren etage mit der dekoration
beginnen das cake pops kurz antrocknen
und ich werde schon mal die große torte
darauf ankleben
das mache ich jetzt wieder mit etwas
zucker kleber damit die torte dann nicht
verrutscht
und jetzt habe ich hier ein stückchen
weißen von dort habe ich etwas cnc bull
verein geknetet damit eben
modelliermasse ergibt und schneller
trocknet das rolle ich jetzt dünn aus
und damit möchte ich jetzt ein paar
russen machen also der untere teil der
torte soll gleich aussehen wie eine rock
und schneidet es da oben so ein land weg
und nehmen wieder diese hölzer als hilfe
und schneidet seien etwa 2 cm breites
band ab
und dann nehme ich mir so ein werkzeug
was aussieht wie ein ball und eine
schaumstoffmatratze so ein bisschen
ausdünnen
dann werde sich das auch gleich ein
bisschen
dann auch gerne mal so in die richtung
dann bestreitet den unteren rand der
torte mit etwas kleber und kriegt dann
nach links herum die nation an
und das macht jetzt immer etappenweise
weil die russen sehr schnell trocknet
deswegen immer so zwei bis drei auf
einmal und dann eben wieder frisch
machen
beim ankleben ist jetzt darauf achten
dass wir das hier so ein bisschen
entfalten legt haben sie dass aus
visionen kleiner unterrock
und wenn ihr jetzt die unterste reihe
habt könnt ihr direkt bei der nächsten
reihe ansetzen und zwar wird die etwas
versetzt direkt rüber angetreten also es
wird in ungefähr hier sein so circa 2 cm
drüber
hier wird schon jetzt fertig und jetzt
habe ich hier roten von dort mit etwas
cnc pulver und rollte es jetzt aus und
steckt dann einen großen kreis aus dem
durchmesser etwas größer ist als die
torte und dann werde ich das als rock
eben gleich darüber leben
und im kreis steche ich jetzt mit meinem
verstellbaren tortenring aus den habe
ich einfach über die torte gelegt und
habe geschaut dass jetzt rechts und
links ungefähr 2 cm abstehen
man kann sich damit ein wunderbar den
kreis ausstechen
die reste könnt ihr übrigens immer
wieder verwerten einfach in etwas
frischhaltefolie oder in einen
gefrierbeutel stecken und dann in einer
schüssel aufbewahren
jetzt kann ich die torte wieder mit
etwas zucker kleber ein pinsel
und mit einem sauberen trockenen pinsel
könnte die bäcker stärke immer wieder
einfach weg potter dann habt ihr diese
weiße oberfläche wieder weg und es ist
auch so ein vorteil von becker stärke
gegenüber von puderzucker und normaler
speisestärke
denn jetzt hier an den rändern ruhig ein
bisschen runter ziehen
und stand die oberfläche wieder glätten
jetzt bin ich es ganz schön wenn man den
roczen ein bisschen entfalten legt das
könnte hier bisschen mit den fingern
machen
die untere torte habe ich jetzt noch mal
im kühlschrank gestellt und mache jetzt
erstmal mit der oberen torte weiter dann
könnte sich nämlich unten diese rüschen
erst mal so ein bisschen antrocknen ich
habe ziel wieder schwarzen von dort
beziehungsweise ich hab's schwarze
modell lade habe das jetzt dünn
ausgerollt und möchte jetzt hier so ein
paar micky maus köpfe dran machen
da stecke ich mir jetzt mit zwei
ausstechen zwei hunde sind das und der
eine hat einen durchmesser von ungefähr
drei zentimetern unter anderem von
glaublich 1,5 cm und da stelle ich mir
jetzt runde kreise aus und prokop
brauche ich natürlich zwei euro also zu
ein großer kreis und zwei kleinen
und die gebe ich jetzt einfach an die
torte und zwar immer so ein bisschen für
selbst mal oben mal weiter unten
da muss man nämlich nicht abmelden
jetzt stehe ich noch ein paar rote
punkte aus und klebt die noch zwischen
die niemand kennt
die medienhaus köpfe bekommen jetzt noch
kleine schleife zwischen die ohren und
dann nehme ich so eine kleine im herbst
ausstecher und steche ich einfach wieder
von diesem roten vom dorf super
herziehen aus und dann brauchen wir
gleich auch noch kleine weiße perlen
damit die ausgesucht hier in die mitte
ein bisschen kleber
herr 2
staubig
aus schwarzem von dort habe ich mir
jetzt ein langes band ausgerollt und
eine seite schon gut abgeschnitten
und jetzt lege ich mich ist und hölzchen
entlang dem ich möchte jetzt hier eine
bordüre dran kleben und da gibt es
verschiedene bordüre stanser da zum
beispiel ich habe da verschiedene motive
und ich habe mehr oder mensch das ist
mir hat mich überzeugt nicht nehmen das
war es etwas verspielter aussieht und
dann kann ich dass damit jetzt
ausstanzen da muss man es einfach
anlegen und andrücken
und dann kann man es einfach wieder
anlegen und das band ebenso lange machen
wie man möchte
dann kann ich auch dieses band einfach
hier unten schon anklingen
wahrscheinlich schneit es jetzt für den
besseren transport hier mal durch dann
reißt es nämlich unterwegs auch nicht
das ist einfach an
werden sie dort jetzt noch mal im
kühlschrank ist mache ich schon mal eine
schleife die kommt nämlich auch mit
obendrauf
und da habe ich mir drohte
modelliermasse ausgerollt also etwas von
dort mit cnc pulver und das sind jetzt
so etwa 12 millimeter und dann schneide
ich mir ein dickes band aus
das darf so etwa sechs zentimeter breite
haben
und dann könnte einfach mal
kontrollieren wenn man das jetzt so
zusammenlegen würde ob es euch von der
größe her passt bei mir passt auf jeden
fall
und jetzt kann ich hier in der mitte so
ein bisschen reinform dass ich setz dich
schleifen mitte
dann nehme ich mir auch gleich zur hilfe
etwas küchenpapier
denn die schleife muss auch gleich in
form gebracht werden
das lege ich mir einmal hin und einmal
auf die andere seite
und jetzt kommt hier in die mitte etwas
zucker kleber
und die schleifen enden hier außen
werden jetzt so ein bisschen gefaltet
dar eingelebt
aus dem rest hier vorm ich mir jetzt
noch dieses band für die mitte da schlag
jetzt aber zuerst die enden um damit den
schöne kante haben
dann hinten einfach fest leben
und so las ich schleife jetzt erstmal
trocknen und dann machen nochmal mit der
torte weiter
ich habe mir jetzt hier ausweisung von
dort ein paar kreise ausgestochen mit
seinem kleineren ausstechen und die
klebe ich jetzt noch alles schön auf den
rock auf
ich habe mir jetzt hier noch ein paar
buchstaben ausgestochen mit hilfe meiner
buchstaben ausstecher einfach aus
schwarzem von dort und die klebe jetzt
auf die oberseite der oberen tor
ich setze jetzt beiden orten zusammen
und damit ich die mitte einigermaßen gut
treffe in dem ich mir jetzt einfach
diese von bentheimer stellt den kurz
hier drauf und kann mir das nur eben
markieren
muss jetzt auch nicht perfekt sein denn
meine torte ist ja größer als der kreis
dann nehme ich mir ein paar logistics
und zwar hat er die obere torte auch im
gewicht und damit sie nicht in die
untere torte mit der zeit ein sieg muss
man eben das mit logistics befestigen
oder zum beispiel mit rundhölzern aus
dem baumarkt ein sieg mehr ein sagt
sorry und dann markiere ich mir jetzt
hier die stelle wo das abschneiden
möchte am besten mit einem lebensmittel
stift
dann nehme ich den stapel daraus kann
hin abschneiden und den eben auch als
vorlage für die anderen stäbe benutzen
und das solltet ihr wirklich auf jeden
fall machen ansonsten geht die untaten
nämlich wirklich kaputt durch das gelegt
und jetzt kann ich die stücke also t
logistics einfach wieder reinstecken und
zwar nehme ich da jetzt etwa sechs stück
haben wir die benötigte sicherheit und
die stabilität muss mal ein bisschen der
architekt spielen
und jetzt kann ich die obere torte auf
die untere draufsetzen
und wenn ihr die torte transportieren
wolltet hättet ihr jetzt unter die
zweite torte auch noch etwas kleber
streichen müssen ich werde sie nicht
transportieren
deswegen brauche ich jetzt keinen kleber
aber ansonsten braucht ihr der
wirklichen kleber damit sie zum beispiel
beim transport nicht verrutschen kann
dort kümmerte tor tritt gleich fertig
stellen
jetzt kann ich hier oben die schleife
noch anbringen und damit die auch gut
steht stecke ich hier jetzt einfach
rechts und links zur ansprache rhein bz
direkt dahinter kann ich jetzt noch die
ohren befestigen
und da wir die schleife ob das jetzt
macht im rockpalast kläglich jetzt hier
noch ein paar punkte drauf kann man
natürlich auch direkt am anfang machen
wir mal die schleife gerade formt oder
man ist sehr einfach
so sieht jetzt die fertige torte aus ich
habe übrigens am rand noch ein kleines
seitenband daran geklebt und zwar mit
etwas dafür seite dem klebeband und die
torte war zwar etwas zeitaufwendige aber
ich finde von der aufmachung her ist sie
relativ einfach
also nicht einfach aber ich würde mal
sagen für leute die schon mal mit von
hand gearbeitet haben ist es ganz okay
auf jeden fall kann man die tore nicht
machen mit solchen handschuhen lissabon
hat die sind bisschen zu groß geld zum
arbeiten
ja und ich hoffe dass ich die torte
gefällt ich finde sie auf jeden fall
super mit gefällt ihr gut
gut hat und ich denke für einen
kindergeburtstag ist es auf jeden fall
die perfekte lösung wenn die der oder
die kleine wobei wahrscheinlich die
kleine in dem mini max taut es sehr
gerne mag und das rezept könnt ihr
nochmal nachlesen auf cds - blog.de da
stehen auch noch mal alle zutaten mit
drauf und ich freue mich schon wieder
auf sechs mal mehr einschaltet bis bald
tut was willst du jetzt du aber nicht
nehmen die pforte wasser mehr auswahl
bei prof
die händler noch nicht beim kanal ab und
bespuckte